hello everyone and welcome to part
seven of my resident evil playthrough
where i
really did spend a lot of time making
sure that i cleared out
everything that i can in this town and i
feel good about it
um but now we are ready to go through
this gate
with the four winged key this is the
only place that i actually can go
everything else is now
officially closed off to me to find the
other like
flask of my baby i guess um
i don't know who was going to be
here i don't think i don't know which of
them
doesn't seem great wow they shifted that
tone smoothly
oh oh my
i do have a body of a doll do you think
this is where i have to find the doll
head
i'm not loving it so far um
[Music]
but i am very impressed by how quickly
they did that oh i have
surely more of them will show up and be
chilling oh i can't meet from them too
oh it had money on it who gave that crow
420
lay my god
okay this doesn't feel great
this is some kind of labyrinth
i guess we did see at the
oh there's just loops
yeah that just took me full circle um
the part where like we found all our
mischievous friends where the thor guy
was there lady d was there
oh no oh no no no okay um there was like
a creepy doll
so maybe that's who we're going to say
hi to huh
can't wait personally don't wait
i disagree i think that's the thing you
want me to shoot uh some some gameplay
engineer forgot to put that in
that should have been interactable oh
[ __ ] hell
he's gonna break when i get off it isn't
it
no
oh everything's coming up ethan winters
[ __ ] you are alive you stupid [ __ ]
okay hello
ethan come with me there's something i
have to tell you
mia yeah am i hallucinating what's going
on
like approximately how far through the
game does she turn into tentacle monster
vampire bat creature
okay what's happened to the music
rose feels different yeah well she's
he's been decapitated you have to fix
her that'll have a
what's that beautiful effect on a baby
as it turns out well i guess i'm going
to get up there
later
[Music]
no that was because you this can't be
real you got
shot about a hundred times
hmm
are they trying to tell me that she is
still alive or are they just trying to
pretend that
oh god oh it's awful
um that ethan cares about her because i
don't buy it
oh my okay
feed from the birds of flesh now she
walks the valley of death
just a nice wholesome thing to
ride on your tombstone you know just
it's great am i losing it
all right i don't feel like this is
going to be fun
give up do i finally get to use this
family photo that i've been making jokes
about the whole time i do
wow now what
what's going on oh i don't like any of
this
oh no okay
wait what
hold up excuse me i would like to know
more about how to
maybe i'm not ready to get it yet
i imagine this has to be a thing that i
unlock somehow
um oh i gotta find that piece maybe okay
we'll come back for you
i'm not forgetting about you treasure i
know what you're about
you shut the door who shut the door
so many emotions at once um okay
great this is this is super nice
it's a little shrine you got here to
this weird like
black ooze that you have on your wall
this
this is great actually i'm
super happy about all of this i can't
wait
i'm sure it's gonna be a very chill
normal time
fun for the whole fam
you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh-huh
this is my life now or i'm just
i hate it when it makes me turn around
this place is haunted as [ __ ]
i have regrets can i go back and hang
out with the duke
he was actually very chill yeah this is
like some kind of hallucinogenic
place which to be fair i love in video
games the scarecrow stuff in batman was
some of my favorite okay that's actually
beautiful
if this want some kind of like [ __ ] up
trip hell hole that would be
a lovely place to stay
think about it what if we just remodel
just a little bit
we just like it's just it's a
fixer-upper what if we just
that was the the one whose name was on
the treasure
you know just out here looking for lock
picks really um procrastinating avoiding
going into the house
because [ __ ] this um and there don't
seem to be any so
cool well we figured it out uh we've
done this level
time to go back to the duke maybe he has
another part
of my baby daughter who is in a job
[Music]
there are so many sounds happening
i go this way i wonder
all right [ __ ] go to the door i feel
like it's gonna be locked anyway
it's not excellent
oh this is beautiful oh oh i could spend
time here this is lovely
oh what was i worried about it's
[ __ ] it's the vacation home i thought
it was from the outside was misleading
they're trying to keep people
away yeah
is that me i never know if it was me i
don't love this
but um otherwise
can i break that
sturdy pots you've got in this one
okay
interesting
this feels fake like
i can interact with so little of it
oh okay i mean yeah there's gonna be
stuff to find in here so
they're not being open bothers me more
that's not great it's not great it's not
great in there
no we don't love it in there okay well
this is interesting you've been you've
been knitting
perfectly normal hobby to do in your
nice summer home i can't interact with
anything in here
that's so [ __ ] suspicious
i don't buy it for a second dude
all right jesus
yeah there's gonna be dolls that come to
life here huh
um but there's there is something here
that you want me to interact with in the
foyer
there is something to be found in the
foyer there's nothing i can find
um
hello okay
i think that this whole place is
probably not going to have anything
in it until maybe like some kind of
later stage
maybe it evolves
i don't love that
you know okay
can you is anybody home
this isn't looking great which means i'm
probably going the right way
okay there it is i didn't go upstairs
but
something that [ __ ] for you um oh
that's where this door is going to lead
me to
wait it's locked from both sides that's
the same door is it not
strange um
i feel like i'm going to come back here
so
not super concerned let's just keep
going for now
alrighty then let's go shall we
what could go wrong
okay hello
lovely buddy
trying to make a friend
i hate it
uh well it's just weird because i feel
like i should hate it but actually i
think it's very nice so far
there's nothing to be looted anywhere so
weird
this is like a very specific design
choice let me tell you
like what is what are you trying to do
to me are you just trying to make me
second-guess myself because i'm freaking
out about there being nothing in here
is it like are you trying to give me a
sense of calm you sadistic [ __ ] explain
yourselves
don't love that okay
still nothing
hmm when a resident evil game doesn't
give you [ __ ] in a hallway
it's all done you know something's wrong
wait wait
it's fine i'm going to leave it to the
end like i did with
cassidy
okay
nice music
[Music]
oh for [ __ ] sake that's actually nice
music
it's not even creepy it's not not it's
not none of it's creepy at all and this
is going to be perfectly fine
nothing is going to go wrong when i take
this
from this doll great
[Music]
what she sounds like moaning myrtle wait
where's my gun she stole my gun how
what rude how the [ __ ]
okay i'll take that thank you um
well hang on let's do this one
okay
i could just tell me they took all my
items
what who the [ __ ] this [ __ ] think she
is
and now that's locked [ __ ]
oh no oh my god
things feel bad i do not like it
i don't have anything [ __ ] you
story of my life man always trying to
find something to fit in that depression
okay there's gonna be [ __ ] something
in here then
[ __ ] me is it on this body maybe
what's all this ethan this is weird
okay yes remove remove
left stick that way
left stick up
that's not left that is definitely up
but okay
great great
this is um i actually find this very
peaceful i'm not supposed to take that
with me
are you sure buddy are you sure
okay if i can say so
this is very odd
huh
this is [ __ ] up dude
what the [ __ ] this is like
[ __ ] none of this is chem fluid
it's like silent hill 2 vibes man
it's so weird not being able to interact
with stuff is so
[ __ ] strange
i don't know why that scared me so much
okay so this is like from the other side
you're telling me son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i have to go back out and it's gonna
look different out there is that is that
what's happened here
is that what you're doing to me here you
[ __ ] of the video game
you stupid [ __ ]
oh oh my
god if i do look that's the one thing
you let me interact with i'm gonna flood
your house you [ __ ] creepy [ __ ]
okay okay
okay i [ __ ] knew it
well that's a lot that's
is this a dollar yeah
oh yeah i can see that her hair's sort
of similar
baby can we like just one more time baby
you know you know what i'm saying
just take me back i could do it with
this doll no worries
ethan i don't think this is that hard
what's the problem
this is this just controls very
strangely
great cool
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is so
something in its mouth but you need some
kind of tool to get it okay
this is very um like soul movie vibes
for me right now
oh you're trying to see some titties no
you're not trying to see some text
oh [ __ ] k
what the [ __ ] was that why did i have
trouble walking away
oh i'm scared of everything [ __ ] sake
yeah just a regular old day
in this video game winding key
okay sweet
that's kind of just going to look at
this again i think
yeah all right well can i use the
winding key in your mouth
my love my sweet my angel
probably not that looks like i do need a
yeah something like tweezers or
something
okay well uh
take a look at your eye there my love oh
my
yep okay
yeah let me go please that's gonna be it
for now um
okay
yeah look at that water bill you thought
you could spook me oh it's all from the
other side [ __ ]
okay i thought i'd be able to get
through that from here um
is this door out here locked
um nothing i can do with this yet okay
hmm this is actually a pretty
compelling puzzle i'm not entirely sure
what i'm supposed to do here
um these two things are going to be
needed the blood-covered ring
is probably the one that's the strangest
um oh there's a number there
you know how i made fun of the only
thing you can interact with
i wonder
hmm
i guess that's how they like gotta give
you clues for this kind of stuff is
make it so limited what you can actually
interact with okay so now i probably
need to just look at that oh and it's
gonna have the code for
that padlock right so we're just gonna
go save again because i like oversaving
cool um
so it says
zero five two nine eleven
zero five wrong way
two nine
uh eleven
okay cool
i think what's the door i came through
it's gonna be different it's gonna be
different it's gonna be different
okay okay
it's the same
is it the same
i'm very unsettled [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's like pt
okay cool
great [ __ ] me
the fact that i don't have
any weapon makes me think this is an
elaborate escape room where nothing's
going to attack me
until like i get a weapon and then
there's going to be a boss fight you can
tell me you're not
of course it's interesting um i don't
know dude because you're being like
cocked or something
oh oh my
[Music]
huh okay cool um
i suspect we have to make
the scratches line up
so it's got to be that's gonna be this
one over here
and then there's a downwards one so
that's that one and then another
upwards one that looks right so far yeah
i think that's it
my god this is creepy okay
that's gonna be for her eye cool
i'm loving all of this this is um
so much like just such a joyous
experience
you know like the door opened
there's nothing to loot
is it darker or am i just terrified
you know fun games for the
whole family really
okay okay
nothing actually bad has happened in
such a long time that when it
does happen i feel like it's going to be
terrible uh yeah open your stupid mouth
get your stupid tweezers
oh
what what can't you tell me like what
can we just talk about it baby
uh
i think i have to go back upstairs then
well that sounds me or are there
something else who knows
yeah i keep wanting to make sure i'm on
the right safe okay
it seems like i have to go back upstairs
fine i'm fine
i'm doing fine this is fun actually
i love video games and uh
i made a career out of it because i have
so much fun
playing video games is this open now
oh that was always open okay i thought
this was upstairs for some reason this
wasn't here before
our happy family rosa's best friend in
the whole wide world she really likes
his fairy tale the most important thing
in the world to us
a wedding gift from grandma proof of
ethan's everlasting love for me
this is from mia
[ __ ] hell okay
film oh
oh i see okay um
rose's best friend in the whole world
that's gonna be
the the monkey
or herself she could be a [ __ ]
narcissist child
she really likes this fairy tale that's
the one that i disagree
she does i don't think she does like it
but whatever
the most important thing in the world to
us a wedding gift from camera proof
through these
proof of ethan's everlasting love is
going to be that
bat
is that right three and four yeah
all right let's [ __ ] play this
[ __ ]
i'm paying too much attention that's how
they get you
who shot this oh [ __ ] sick
did i even get the part of my baby
imagine explaining the plot of this game
to somebody who doesn't play video games
did i even get the baby part oh my
oh oh secret passage i believe they call
them
is there somewhere here that i can save
i'm uncomfortable
okay cool
[ __ ] all of this
who gave you these scissors oh
it wants me to go cut the
the um the advantages of the doll
because it's always here did i not see
this somehow this weird [ __ ]
like who did this who the [ __ ]
you know
oh oh no i'm in a new area
mom
okay cool
great great
that's [ __ ] all right pt you [ __ ]
please ethan listen to me i didn't
want to keep it from you
did she sacrifice herself for this
village or some [ __ ]
or is it all a lie that's the problem is
i don't know
it's possible that she intentionally
sacrificed the baby because she's a [ __ ]
where am i
i'm gonna need a baby symbol no babies
aren't gonna fit into idea of depression
love
that's not a good idea i feel like i've
gone the wrong way
where am i oh
oh okay we're just going back to the
doll workshop oh that's fine
okay it's just a loop
ugh
you [ __ ] [ __ ] can we have a
conversation about whatever it is that
you did
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh my god
okay this is actually
a great time no that's a mistake
i'm actually having so much fun playing
this right now
very confident cool and calm
[Laughter]
jesus am i going to take a titty
nice okay yeah cool yeah
great yep say [ __ ] peace
say it
my wife is a [ __ ]
okay great all right
this is like
so tense in such a weird way
oh that's gonna be the three eyes and
then this one
is going to be the bird that was in her
eye would it look like that one
that one i think that one
no um oh three closed eyes
yeah it's that
was one of them open is this a trick
or am i just very forgetful
give me your arm woman
oh they're all closed and how's your eye
take a look at this again it is flying
to the right
which is probably the one i made a
mistake i have it flying left
correct
oh this is the video oh my god
oh geez oh cheesy cheesy cheesy cheese
cheeses cheese big fan of
gammon bear do i even like him a bit i'm
just lying to make myself feel
comfortable
i like brie
and a mild cheddar [ __ ] this
i'm also a fan
[Music]
that right that was that whole bit was
unintentional i'm just trying to calm
myself down
because this is the worst thing that
i've ever done um in anything ever
okay hang on isn't there a quick tone
what is it b there is one i just forget
what it
no i scared myself because i got back on
the ladder
oh oh okay
is that that wasn't me was it
the [ __ ] did that come from
what if i leave no it's ahead of me
oh my god oh it's so
silent hill uh safe
just let me save real quick thank you
cool it's just a second of silence you
know when you get to save
ew what the [ __ ]
can i just get back to the breaker box
real fast
oh god this is like one of the
what the [ __ ]
it ah jesus christ
um oh it's moved something in has moved
oh my god can i get out through here now
or do i have to go full circle
what oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh god where are you [ __ ] coming from
i don't know where it is uh there
mother's door
maybe now i haven't gotten anything new
though
the breaker box is it's um
it's it's
where is it i don't [ __ ] remember
anymore [ __ ]
where is this [ __ ] thing
this i can't open yet
sure why not
you know this
i think this is right
[ __ ] god
did i do that correctly
okay
great can i please leave
holy [ __ ] i thought that's
oh okay what the [ __ ] oh
oh oh i see
it's like an item to use
[ __ ] [ __ ]
okay well it can't get inside this wall
thing i assume
but i don't know where it is
oh man
this is real [ __ ] up
oh god oh god is that always there oh
well
okay giant baby is that it for us like
where am i now
okay i'm back here
[ __ ] hell this is still locked
no oh my god no it's quiet again
i don't like it
i'm very concerned right now
why is this a dead end
i keep expecting i have something in
them oh i can hide in them
oh that means this room's not safe
okay
oh my god okay
um i have to go the whole [ __ ] way
around right
yeah yeah i do yeah
oh god i don't even know if i'm being
chased anymore well surely i am that's
why they made it dark again
raped great
fun for everyone
having a super good time i just go back
through the study back through the study
alana
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
okay i know where i can hide
i know where i can hide stupid [ __ ]
dick [ __ ] baby
[ __ ] this is why i don't want kids
this is the only place in here is it
just gonna go away
oh my god
i miss lady d so much i just missed that
so much
cause she come back instead baby
i'm pretty sure this is what i was
supposed to do
this feels scripted right
what are you what are you doing what are
you doing
i kind of want to see what happens if it
finds me but i'm not going to take that
kind of chance
get out just leave
you wait till sound goes away i played a
survival horror game in my time
d spawn please
it may have
should i go back to the medicine room to
save
or the dollar workshop i mean you know
i'm very committed to saving
it's it's a thing you know it's really
important to be
i probably shouldn't
hey at least i know if i need to
there's that one and then there's the
one in
medicine
this makes me think i'm getting closer
to it
okay where do i go from here up
back to the study back to that crawl
space
oh no oh
stupid [ __ ] babies man just getting
their mess all over the place
inconsiderate oh it's [ __ ] dark
well at least i get to save um
back to my nice save you save point
where i just feel a moment of peace
and from here we go up around
i don't feel like this is going to go
well for me
i don't have a gun i can't even kill it
is this someone i hide in the storage
room
where the [ __ ] did it go
oh my god okay it
is somehow well i don't know why i'm
questioning
the logic bro what the [ __ ]
oh my god
leave me alone dude i'm just trying to
get on an elevator
oh [ __ ] wait wait is my crawl space gone
oh [ __ ]
oh no okay okay
okay oh god oh god oh god oh god can i
can i go
holy [ __ ] oh my god faster oh oh my god
oh my god oh my god no no no no no get
get
go go go
this is a lot
why is the screen old
why is the baby
what why i probably need to go upstairs
i thought that i'd be okay for like a
second you know and i'm not
oh my god okay
oh i don't feel good about any of this
is it you that's i don't know who's
laughing
sort of a part of my [ __ ] [ __ ]
who did this oh
don't leave i can't let you
oh she's the one
[Music]
get back here stupid [ __ ] try and find
me
okay upstairs
oh my god okay what and i'm gonna die if
i don't find you
what [ __ ] sick game is this
crazy [ __ ]
oh that's a
did i do it
real parental abuse
okay
oh my god what in the [ __ ]
um okay
this seems right the [ __ ] have you gone
no no wait was that her no
[ __ ] i assume that i will actually die
if i don't find her where have you gone
where have you [ __ ] gone there's too
many [ __ ] dolls
oh oh oh oh
no stop you [ __ ] hater
okay i've not been this way so this
seems like a good bit
nope can't go that way where the [ __ ]
have you gone now
[ __ ] back upstairs i don't know
i don't know man
oh okay cool yeah hey what's up
jolie there are only three
stupid idiot what are you doing to my
cute friends
this is not what i was expecting from
this game
oh my
it's over i don't know about that ethan
i don't know about that
we may have completed the house though
[Applause]
oh nothing's right did i do the house
that's the key that
what okay
good i need to get out of this in
agreement
okay yeah cool
okay cool wow um who's behind all this
was that a [ __ ]
what
and i still haven't [ __ ] searched the
foyer out properly have i oh here we go
i don't know that i want her but if you
[ __ ] insist
um jesus
that was oh my god
just you know just a whole
holy [ __ ]
like extremely just
stressful [ __ ] time in a way that i
don't i didn't expect
is everything gonna be do i want to go
down
surely i'm gonna have to fight some some
people on the way back probably but
like i'm so tense and my stomach is
just a lot dude
yeah i feel like resident evil doesn't
get like weird like that all that often
i appreciated it but [ __ ] damn
i feel like i i need a massage you know
it's
oh
um okay i was intentionally looking down
so i know which way to go
would would love to save again uh you
know me you know how i feel about saving
but let's go for that
i don't feel like this is gonna be super
easy
i could be wrong what do i know
can i get this treasure now
what is this dungeon kitchen treasure oh
that was from
um so i caught yet
but i have an extra key now right and
it's not just that key
no hmm okay
i thought that maybe there'd be a key to
get up to that higher area but
oh maybe that's why that was there
i cannot um okay was this open before
i think it was or i would have done this
um
i'm just expecting the lycan to show up
now that way back outside
are you alive sir
maybe we should just can't craft
anything right just go through this nice
little turtle
anyone
anyone around
anybody is that gonna be the peace
sun and moon bowl
bud maybe he's just dead maybe the
baby they're all just dead just actually
dead dead and i just need to leave him
oh a new shotgun i was gonna say
leave them to rest in peace [ __ ] me i
guess
these guys are more like zombies
you're gonna get through there
eventually unsure
oh i thought that i guess it's a much
slower shotgun
than the other one okay i'm not used to
it yet
they are going to get through oh my mind
um okay
everyone could just [ __ ] die that'd
be tight oh
hello
[Applause]
i think somebody might still be alive
but i do think i'll also be okay
we're all right with it
okay
thank you for all of the things did i
loot that house i did
break this [ __ ] box
move my new gun down yeah we can figure
that out later
hello mate can i kill you before you
even get up
yeah sweet uh
okay that's blocked off
i expected that to have a crystal shot
in it
um i could go either way that would be
back to where i came from oh so this is
that i just looped okay
this is that the place where the tree
fell down
oh there's a wheel make a pizza in there
what kind of pizza you making margarita
pepperoni
whatever you want
ah that's for the other side of
this stupid [ __ ]
i hate dolls now i actually had no
problem with them prior
now [ __ ]
never give a kid a doll
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
i really keep expecting someone to beat
it i don't have a strange bird
that's interesting that must indicate
something um okay let's go into this
[ __ ] of a house where somebody's
gonna attack me again
you [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm sorry so let's see
what i apologize
alright star it's not a problem where
i'm from
uh but i try not to say it on youtube
luther's key oh that's the um
that's the the the house that i can't
get into in the town
uh this is gonna be sun and moon ball
this labyrinth
oh cool
it's it's moving the whole time and yet
for some reason i just didn't clock that
keep you real slow but just nice and
just easing it down okay a little bit
further and then you just sort of come
back around here
yep good okay
cool yep good good good good good
yeah oh
look at the confetti look i did it yes
we're all very proud of me thank you
that was cool um okay so i'm very
bothered by the fact that i haven't
gotten that yet
but i can always come back here
just across the bridge
i'm supposed to go home that way
either way i'm gonna save right here and
this is where we're gonna leave it
this time my friends
um thank you all for watching i will see
you in my next pot which will probably
be recorded while i'm in a hotel room in
australia so i look forward to that
hopefully it works out okay and i'm able
to record more
i'll see you guys next time thank you
bye oh
my webcam's been frozen for how long has
it been frozen for
that's not ideal i had no idea wow